information today we're going to talk
about using Ares for course reserves now
just a level set course reserves if
you're not familiar with it it
course-related material that's made
available either electronically or
physically and generally to the library
that's providing these services and at
Yale we use a system called Ares it is
the supported platform for providing
access to these course reserves so just
some brief information about what the
service is so it's a commercial vendor
supported software package made by Atlas
systems at Yale it launched in the fall
of 2013 and it's been you know online
since and the service is managed by the
library and runs on University IDs
infrastructure so just talking about how
it's being used currently across the
university Yale College Arts and
Sciences the graduate school and school
management are the key users of the
system medical and law schools haven't
yet used it yet just to give you a sense
of I guess how it's being used in the
activity in the system roughly 500
courses for this spring that are using
it about 10,000 reserve items and then
when it comes to electronic resources
there have been roughly 52 thousand
downloads this spring so it's a fairly
you know actively used system if you're
unfamiliar with Ares just to talk about
the various roles that users play within
the system so faculty or their
designated users place things on reserve
and it's the library staff that then
takes those requests and process them
processes them and makes them available
and then the students view that reserve
material I don't know if you're familiar
with you know if you've encountered
other systems in the past if you've used
Ares but in case you're curious you know
benefits of Ares I think the biggest
thing it's really tightly integrated
with canvas so that's why we're here you
gain access to it using you know one
credential one place to visit and you
gain access to that user interface
through canvas which is huge so
instructors can place reserve requests
online you don't need to come to the
library you
to do it anymore to take a book and put
it on a request that's all automated
instructors this is a nice feature
instructors can arrange in tag reserve
items to organize their courses so if
you put 30 items on reserve you know you
have a 15 16 week semester you could tag
it in such a way that your students know
exactly when to you know interact with
the material and I'll show you an
example of that in a minute this is a
big one I think for the library and the
university in terms of risk there's a
lot of issues swirling around about
copyright and copyright Clearance for
reserved items and the area systems has
a very nice workflow that the library
staff used to validate that things are
in fact appropriate you know to use in
the class for your students and we will
pay Vanessa the publishers whatever fees
are associated with disseminating that
information so you know that if you're
using the system material is okay to use
and you're not going to get a call from
anymore finally you know it's a nice
place to go and check accuracy of your
reserved lists and and much like Panopto
you can get a quick sense of what the
statistic statistical usage of is of the
various items on reserve benefits for
students a couple nice things again you
know tightly integrated with canvas they
they only have one place to go to look
at this stuff they have access to their
print reserve collections and e research
reserve x' collection in one place
so that's books that are you know put on
a shelf here in this library or it's
links out to websites or PDFs or other
materials all in one place for students
this seems like it's a fairly popular
service they could enable the system to
alert them when new items go on reserve
for a class so they get immediate
notification that hey you know this
professor put this book on reserve they
can also set it up in such a way that it
tells them hey you know I'm going to set
up a reminder to remind me that in two
weeks I need to look at this particular
item and finally this solution is a
document it's a place to host the
material so if you upload PDFs they
reside in Aires so students can go and
log in interact with the content or
download it for later use so it's also a
publishing platform
this is just one example of a course in
canvas and you'll notice here circled in
red is where course reserves will pop up
I believe when you actually populate
that list and then this is the student
view if you actually click through to
course reserves you can see I don't know
I don't know how big it is but on the
bottom part of the screen are the actual
items that are on reserve in this case
it's physical material that you know if
they would actually click through to
that any of those items it would
probably say oh go to the batch library
go to CSS si up the hill or wherever if
it's web pages or web resources it's
just links out if it's PDFs you can
download the thing there thank you so
I'm going to hand it off to you on
they're not okay
hi I'm up at the hill at CSS si but all
of the units who do reserves and put
things on reserve for you work together
as a group we refer things out to other
libraries just have a few frequently
asked questions that I thought I would
mention do I have to provide the
material to the library no you can
upload what you like we'll be looking at
copyright so it'll automatically the
default is to check for copyright but
you can tell us get it for us and we'll
get the article for you or the book
sometimes we don't have the book well
order the book we'll look at how many
students are in the class so if you can
if you know how many students are in the
class you can put that information into
the course record that will help us and
figuring out how many copies of a book
we need to have do I need to tag each
reserve item it's a really good idea to
tag each reserve item otherwise it's
hard for people to find things we get
frantic calls usually Sunday night my
professor didn't put so there's an
article supposed to be here and it's not
here often is because they don't know
they can sort by tags or because it
wasn't tagged and so they're having
trouble finding it and we you should
calm them down and help them find it
so if you say this is this is for first
class or the first week by time or date
it's probably preferable to do by class
in a way because if you reuse a list the
next year the dates will be different so
if you use the you know first class
second class that kind of thing and four
zero two to nine if you use zero nine
zero one zero two zero three so that it
will inter file correctly it's fussy
like that but that's one of the few
fussy thinks about it and you can tag
them with whatever you want if you want
to use topic instead of time so this is
the topic we're talking about for the
next three weeks you can you can buy
this information today we're going to
talk about using Aries for course
reserves you know just a level set
course reserves if you're not familiar
with it it course-related material
that's made available either
electronically or physically and
generally to the library that's
providing these services and at Yale we
use a system called Aries it is the
supported platform for providing access
to these course reserves so just some
brief information about what the service
is so it's a commercial vendor supported
software package made by atlas systems
at Yale it launched in the fall of 2013
and it's been you know online since and
the service is managed by the library
and runs on University IDs
infrastructure so just talking about how
it's being used currently across the
university Yale College Arts and
Sciences the graduate school and school
management are the key users of the
system medical and law schools haven't
yet used it yet just to give you a sense
of I guess how it's being used in the
activity in the system roughly 500
courses for this spring that are using
it about 10,000 reserve items and then
when it comes to electronic resources
there have been roughly 52 thousand
downloads this spring so it's a fairly
you know actively new system if you're
unfamiliar with Ares just to talk about
the various roles
that users play within the system so
faculty or their designated users place
things on reserve and it's the library
staff that then takes those requests and
process them processes them and makes
them available and then the students
view that reserve material I don't know
if you're familiar with you know if
you've encountered other systems in the
past if you've used Ares but in case
you're curious you know benefits of Ares
I think the biggest thing it's really
tightly integrated with canvas so that's
why we're here you gain access to it
using you know one credential one place
to visit and you gain access to that
user interface through canvas which is
huge so instructors can place reserve
requests online you don't need to come
to the library to you know to do it
anymore to take a book and put it on
request that's all automated instructors
this is a nice feature instructors can
arrange in tag reserve items to organize
their courses so if you put 30 items on
reserve you know you have a 15 16 week
semester you could tag it in such a way
that your students know exactly when to
you know interact with the material and
I'll show you an example of that in a
minute this is a big one I think for the
library and the University in terms of
risk there's a lot of issues swirling
around about copyright and copyright
Clearance for reserved items and the
area systems has a very nice workflow
that the library staff used to validate
that things are in fact appropriate you
know to use in the class for your
students and we will pay the nets the
publishers whatever fees are associated
with disseminating that information so
you know that if you're using the system
the material is okay to use and you're
not going to get a call from any lawyer
finally you know it's a nice place to go
and check accuracy of your reserved
lists and and much like Panopto you can
get a quick sense of what the statistic
is statistical usage are is of the
various items on reserve benefits for
students a couple nice things again you
know tightly integrated with canvas they
only have one place to go to look at
this stuff they have access to their
print reserve collections anda research
reserve x' collection in one place
so that's books that are you know put on
a shelf here in this library or it's
links out to websites or PDFs or other
materials all in one place for students
this seems like it's a fairly popular
service they could enable the system to
alert them when new items go on reserve
for a class so they get immediate
notification that hey you know this
professor put this book on reserve they
can also set it up in such a way that it
tells them hey you know I'm going to set
up a reminder to remind me that in two
weeks I need to look at this particular
item and finally this solution is a
document it's a place to host the
material so if you upload PDFs they
reside in Aires so students can go and
log in interact with the content or
download it for later use so it's also a
publishing platform this is just one
example of a course in canvas and you'll
notice here circled in red is where
course reserves will pop up I believe
when you actually populate that list and
then this is the student view if you
actually click through to course
reserves you can see I don't know how
big it is but on the bottom part of the
screen are the actual items that are on
reserve in this case it's physical
material that you know if they would
actually click through to that any of
those items it would probably say oh go
to the best library go to CSS si up the
hill or wherever if it's web pages or
web resources it's just links out if
it's PDFs you can download the thing
there thank you so I'm going to hand it
off to you I'm Mary Beth okay hi
I'm up at the hill at CSS si but all of
the units to do reserves and put things
on reserve for you work together as a
group
we refer things out to other libraries
just have a few frequently asked
questions that I thought I would mention
do I have to provide the material to the
library no you can upload what you like
we'll be looking at copyright so it'll
automatically the default is to check
for copyright but you can tell us get it
for us and we'll get the article for you
or the book sometimes we don't have the
book well order the book we'll look at
how many students are in the class so if
you can
if you know how many students are in the
class you can put that information into
the course record that will help us and
figuring out how many copies of a book
we need to have do I need to tag each
reserved item it's a really good idea to
tag each reserved item otherwise it's
hard for people to find things we get
frantic calls usually Sunday night my
professor didn't put it so there's an
article supposed to be here and it's not
here
often is because they don't know they
can sort by tags or because it wasn't
tagged and so they're having trouble
finding it and we you should calm them
down and help them find it so if you say
this is this is for a first class or the
first week by time or date it's probably
preferable to do by class in a way
because if you reuse a list the next
year the dates will be different so if
you use the you know first class second
class that kind of thing and for 0 2 to
9 if you use 0 9 0 1 0 2 0 3 so that it
will inter file correctly it's fussy
like that but that's one of the few
fussy thinks about it and you can tag
them with whatever you want if you want
to use topic instead of time so this is
the topic we're talking about for the
next three weeks you can you can tag
them with time and topic next question
what is a pickup location we fixed it so
it's easier there used to be a default
of bass library so if you didn't catch
that you needed to choose a pickup
location or your request for processing
went to bass and since they're the
largest provider of reserves on campus
that could have put you back farther in
the queue pickup location is where you
would like print materials to be for
your students and that that varies
depending on what you're teaching
we're CSS si is the sciences but the
engineering collection is down
here and so bass provides reserves
processing for engineering questions
okay so thank you any questions I was
hoping someone would do that so we have
a guideline that we will do 20% it's a
guideline so it's a little soft around
the edges but 20% of a book we have had
requests if the book is out of copyright
and we have the time and the staffing we
can do much more but 20%
[Applause]
[Music]